i'm glad we got him here though we'll
take pete here right
74 degrees our high for the day today 46
overnight for the low we warmed up quite
a bit from yesterday because
yesterday high was 67. we told you get
back in those 70s and there you go the
record on this day 84 degrees
set back in 1972. all right currently
outside we start off for the far west
side of the valley summerlin 67 for you
72 in centennial hills let's head up to
alliant takes 71 right now
73 downtown north las vegas double
sevens looking good out there in the far
west side of valley for sunrise manor
and green valley 75. rhodes ranch
mountain's edge both at 73
75 currently for henderson at this hour
good to see these milder temperatures
these are comfortable temperatures
outside and that goes for prompt too 75
for you
74 for boulder city 80 already in
laughlin right now still in 78
up in northeast clark there in mesquite
our radar network again
sweeping around not picking up any
precip we know that's going to
obviously change next week but clouds up
the northwest corner of the state no
rain from that though but we've got
several systems that we're watching high
pressure right here in charge is giving
us the milder temperatures
this is the one that's going to give us
some wind tomorrow and this one
way out here near the aleutian islands
is going to affect us
early on next week first let's focus on
that
first one that's going to bring us
clouds on sunday wind tomorrow clouds on
sunday no rain though
but that second one i pinpointed out to
you look at this by wednesday slight
chances for showers to return we're not
talking widespread or great chances
just in the slight category for
wednesday that's wednesday night
and also maybe thursday morning too for
south clark
and then that clears out of here by the
time we get to thursday afternoon and
evening so we're going to get wind
tomorrow those gusts
near 30 to 35 maybe even monday and
tuesday we will see those gusts even
higher at the 35 to close to 40 breezy
on wednesday no wind advisories have
been issued just yet that could change
for next week 50 overnight chilly and
quiet a nice night tonight if you're
gonna be out about 77 for tomorrow
great to see the temperatures warming up
however we do have to deal
with those breezy to gusty winds where
those gusts like we said
could peak up to 35 in some spots highs
tomorrow in the high
70s across the valley looking good 74 in
summerlin 75 cent tenney hills
76 mountains edge north las vegas 76 for
you downtown henderson
at 75 degrees we'll be at 74 for pump
same goes for state line
at prim here's your most accurate eight
on the eight
windy again early on next week like we
talked about there's your temperature
drop on tuesday 74 monday
65 on tuesday slight shower chances
midweek
temperatures will stay cool for most of
the week and then gradually warm up to
the high 60's
by the end of the week next week that's
your most accurate forecast
back over to you